Voiceover: Here's some
questions that I got from
Brainwave, a children's
science magazine in India.
The first question right here
is last month, September,
the students of the world
celebrated Teacher's Day,
an overwhelming number of whom would
undoubtedly have sent their wishes and
gratitude your way.
Hopefully and I thank
everyone for all of the
thank you notes we do get on our YouTube
channel and all the rest.
Who was your favorite teacher while
studying and why?
I'd have to say I had a
bunch of favorite teachers
for, I guess, multiple
reasons, but I guess there is
a common thread.
I would say in high
school the teachers who,
and I don't want to just pick favorites,
I'm sure I'm forgetting some
very important people here,
but Mr. Hernandez.
The first time I had a
class with him was for
Algebra II, but he was
also the adviser for,
it was called Mu Alpha
Theta, which was the
Math Honor Society and also
the math competition team.
He was our adviser for
that and Miss. Kennedy.
She was an English teacher
and also a journalism instructor.
When I was on the school newspaper,
she was our teacher and our adviser.
I think what made both
of them memorable to me
and I think were important
in my own development
is that they really did
treat me like a peer.
They never talked down to me.
It never felt like,
"I am the teacher, you are the student."
It was kind of a two-way
flow of information.
It almost felt like we
were working together
towards a common goal.
Mr. Hernandez with some of the stuff
we did with the math team.
Miss Kennedy with some of the stuff
we would do with the newspaper.
She was just a person who was
more knowledgeable and more experienced,
but she really respected everything that
we were doing.
I think probably all of the teachers
that I had that I think
really impacted me,
that's what did it for me is that.
I remember even in 5th
grade I had a teacher,
Ms. Ellis and she would run her 5th grade
social studies classes kind
of like a college seminar.
I distinctly remember her being
at the front of the class,
peeling an orange,
and just asking us tough questions.
The type of questions where you'd have to
ponder it for a few seconds
before you'd even have an
interesting thought or you would
continue pondering it when you went home.
I remember there was Miss Krause and
Miss Rucell in elementary school.
They were gifted teachers
and once again, they had
the luxury of defining what
their own curriculum was.
They really used to
challenge us and give us
truly creative projects to work on.
When you take art class outside of that,
oftentimes it's very
formulaic, it's kind of
paint by numbers for
lack of a better word,
but I remember when we did art projects
in the context of the gifted class,
it was really very open-ended.
It was like here's some
tools; make something
and I think that was a
really strong message and
allowed students to really
develop their creativity
as opposed to just following a formula.
Across the board, I think
it's the teachers who
really expected something
from the students
and treated them with
respect, even though these
students were clearly
early in their learning.
Also, assumed that the students were
capable of true creativity.
I'll throw another one
in there, Dr. Santania.
My junior and senior year in
high school, I took courses
at the University of New
Orleans and Dr. Santania
was the professor for partial
differential equations.
He brought me under his
wing and for a summer I was
essentially one of his researchers.
He would come into the little
computer lab where I was
working and he would
talk about his research.
We would bounce ideas off of each other.
Clearly, here you are a tenured
professor at a university,
but you're willing to hang
out with a 16- or 17-year-old.
It really sent a very strong
message to me and really
I think built my own self-esteem and
made me think that I could do something.
Question number two;
what sort of a student
were you at school?
I was a kid who loved,
so I loved - this is kind
of an interesting answer
I think - I loved a lot of
the subject matter and I
hated a lot of the classes.
I found a lot of the
subject matter really,
really, really interesting;
I just didn't like how it was sometimes
presented and it wasn't
the fault of the teacher.
It was often more usually
the fault I would say of
the textbook or of just
the curriculum generally.
The general idea, everything
was devoid of connections.
You would learn how to
borrow numbers without anyone
telling you why you were borrowing that
or even without anyone
ever asking the students
why does this work,
without ever having the chance to ponder
why does it work.
You'd see peers memorize
one formula for one exam
and then on the next exam
or by the next month,
they'd forgotten it and
the next year when there's
a topic that just builds
off of that same formula,
if you just intuitively
understood the original formula
the second one would be intuitive,
they're rememorizing an ex-formula.
I really didn't like that
aspect of what was going on
and I sometimes, I think
for lack of a better word,
I think I sometimes
acted up because of that.
I straightened up a
little bit near the end of
high school, but earlier
on I wasn't like the
discipline problem kid, but
I definitely got a lot of
teachers talking to my
mom about Sal not being
fully engaged in class.
I think once I got to
college, I was lucky enough
to go to a place where there
was a lot of intellectual
curiosity going on.
There was a culture of
people wanting to learn
and I frankly think MIT is
somewhat unique in that.
The culture really is,
there's other things going on
on campus, but most of
the people there genuinely
want to learn and there's
no embarrassment of saying
you're actually fascinated
by something academic.
While at a lot of schools
in the world, you almost
have to hide that you're
interested in something.
I know that was definitely
the case in my high school
experience is that I would
not, even if I was fascinated
by something, I would keep
it to myself and sometimes
even if I did enjoy talking
to the teacher, I would
actually keep that to myself.
I wouldn't want my peers
seeing that I was even or
sometimes I wouldn't talk
to the teacher for fear of
looking like you're
trying to be teacher's pet
or something and I think sometimes I would
maybe overcompensate
in the other direction.
I would say - I'm giving
a long meandering answer -
I would say as a student, I was
definitely intellectually curious.
I definitely liked to ponder things.
I did not like to be
given; I didn't like to
paint by numbers I guess is
the simple way to do it and
I oftentimes butted heads
with parts of the school
system that wanted you to paint by numbers
and wanted you to move lock-step
with everyone else and wanted you to
just accept things
without questioning them.
Yes, sometimes that led to some issues.
Number three; could you
tell us about any one
experience or epiphany
that you may have had
while growing up that shaped your attitude
towards learning and teaching?
There's a bunch.
I think one story is that
we tell often now because
Shantanu now works at the Khan Academy,
he's the president here.
I first met him in 10th
grade at a math competition
and we met in the finals
at the math competition.
It was a district wide math competition.
In the last round it was
me, Shantanu and there was
another boy and Shantuna
did beat me and so that was
a good experience, a
humbling experience, but
above and beyond that
while we were competing,
we actually had a little
bit of a conversation.
It actually turned out
that even though we were
both in the same grade, he was
a math class ahead of me.
I asked him, I was like
how does that happen?
He said, "Well, I just
tested out of the math class
you're taking right now."
For me, that was an
epiphany that one, that was
even a possibility.
I then went back to my high school and
went back to the administration.
I said, "Hey, can I test out of stuff?"
They're like, "Oh, we're not
aware of anything like that."
What Shantanu did was he
awakened the possibility
that you can do that.
It ended up being a lot
harder, not harder in terms
of the subject matter
mastery, but a lot harder in
terms of convincing the
system that you should be
allowed to test out of something and
once you prove that you know something,
you should be allowed to
go on to the next thing.
That gave me the energy
to do it and that really
did accelerate my own learning
and frankly that allowed
me to have a lot of
those experiences that I
just mentioned; someone like Dr. Santania.
I would have never ended up taking partial
differential equations at
the University of New Orleans
while in high school had I
not had that conversation
with Shantanu that opened
my mind to the idea
that you really can, for
lack of a better word,
fight the system and go at your own pace.
I think other learnings,
once I started taking classes
at the university even in
high school, university
class attendance was
completely optional and I
sometimes I took advantage
of that and I realized
that I did learn a lot
better from a book than
oftentimes in a lecture.
It wasn't that lectures
are fundamentally bad.
I mean here I am making
all these YouTube Videos.
It's just that the book
allowed me to learn
at my own pace.
If I was confused by
something, I could read the
same passage ten times.
If I found something easy,
I could just skim something.
In lecture, it was hard to stay engaged.
I always found that I was
either lost or I was bored.
Very few times in a lecture that I was
exactly at the right place,
exactly connecting with
the pace of the class.
At the Univeristy of New
Orleans, where I spent
essentially my 11th and
12th grades in high school,
I, to a large degree,
showed up for the exams
but did a lot of self-paced study and that
carried with me when I
went to MIT is that I
realized that class time
maybe it works for some,
but didn't work a lot for me.
I would have loved class
time that was interactive,
that was hands on.
I loved lab time.
In all my computer science
classes, I would skip
class and go to the
computer lab and work on my
projects and I felt I was
learning the material much
better than sitting in a
300 person lecture hall
and listening to a
lecture about something.
It was much better to
fiddle with the thing.
I think the ideal would
have been having videos
on demand so that if I
was curious about a topic,
I could get some videos, pause, repeat,
watch them as much as I
need to, but then have all
this extra time and
preferably with the rest of my
peers and professor around so that I could
actually fiddle with
stuff and build stuff.
That's where I feel the
best learning happens.
That's what we're trying to
do with the Khan Academy.
We're trying to make class
time about interaction
and about fiddling and
about helping each other,
letting humans be humans and allow
a lot of the core skills to
happen at someone's own pace
through on demand video
and through exercise.
I want to be clear.
I said that I liked textbooks
a lot and I still like
textbooks; I'm reading
many right now, but I think
a combination of on demand
videos and exercises that
give immediate feedback can be better
for the purposes of self-paced learning.
When I was 16 and I was
trying to chug through
some type of an analysis book
or a partial differential
equations book, it's dense
reading and you had to be
very persistent to read through that.
I would have loved a ten
minute video on the exact
topic that I was ready
for and I would have loved
practice problems where
you don't just have every
other answer at the back of the book.
You have immediate
feedback; you know how to do
the steps of that problem.
You know what videos to
watch if you don't know
how to do that problem and
the videos are not just
dry text; it's actually
someone trying to communicate
intuition to you, trying to communicate
not just the methodology but really
the art of the mathematics or science.
Question number four; what
excites you most about
learning science?
It really is that science
is all about really
trying to find the truth in the universe.
We'll never probably
know all the truth in the
universe, but I think
that's what separates humans
from every other species
that we know is that
we are just naturally
curious and we are naturally
in awe of the mysteries of this universe.
Science is our best tool at trying to
demystify the mysterious.
Frankly what is does is it
just introduces even more
and even more profound mysteries
the deeper and deeper you go into science.
Just this journey of
working on the Khan Academy
videos, I've gone so
much deeper in so many
areas of science, but
it's given me so much more
appreciation for how much
deeper the open questions
are and so I think science,
when someone is really in
science, it caters to that
part of the human instinct
that gives you awe, that
you start to appreciate
where you are in the universe
and what the universe
might be about or how
intertwined and elegant the
universe that we're in actually is.
It's just exciting.
Question number five; as
a teacher who has impacted
so many lives, do you
have any advice for our
young readers who find
it hard to concentrate on
their studies or perform well in exams?
Yes, my main advice is as much as you can,
try to ponder what you are learning.
Don't just try to cram for an exam.
Don't try to memorize formulas.
If you feel that the formulas
you're looking at for
your current class are just
beyond your understanding,
then back up, look at what
you learned last year,
the year before.
Get to a point where
you can start to see why
those things are intuitive
and hopefully you watch
Khan Academy videos and
that's what we try and do.
Show you why these things are intuitive,
why they aren't formulas to memorize.
Once you start to ponder
things, you'll just start
to ponder things all the time.
My wife jokes that it often
takes me a half an hour
to throw out the trash
because I take out the trash
and while I'm holding the
trash can, I sometimes am
just staring out at the
sky for like ten minutes
because I'm pondering something.
This may be the most
fun thing to be doing is
pondering something
and the more you ponder
something, it gets your brain
just building connections.
Then as you progress through more and more
advanced courses, they'll
just start to seem
more and more obvious.
You'll almost say why
is this a new course.
This is just a natural
by-product of what I had already
pondered and frankly it will help you
not just in your academics.
I think it will help you
be a more creative person.
That's frankly what really,
really, really matters
is the ability to see
things where maybe other
people aren't seeing things,
see better ways of doing things,
seeing innovations, seeing connections
that other people aren't seeing.
I would say ponder as much as you can,
learn as deeply as you can,
make sure that your foundations are as
strong as you can and after
that, if there is the mundane
aspects and there are mundane
aspects of our current
school systems and our
current exams, just view
that as a game, as a
game that lets you get
to the good stuff and
that's how I viewed it.
There are definitely
moments in my own education
where I was like this is
silly, they're making me
do this or that, but I
said I have to do this if I
want to get to a point
where I get to do more
pondering and I get to look
at the really cool stuff.
Yes, I would say ponder
as much as you can,
so that you can really
distill things to what's
most important and then
the stuff that's still not
fun after that, just
remind yourself it's a bit
of a marathon and it's
going to get you to where
you're going so that your
life will be more fun at
some point and hopefully it's already
a little fun right now.